okay so just stay cool let me handle
this
these people are kind of touchy Seth you
can't say these people everyone's an
individual of their own free will with
their own flippin I get that you got
into like nine Ivy League schools just
because you're a celebrity but this is
time to screw around these people will
kill you
we're all just human being so shut up
here it comes here comes hey sad Frank
oh my boys how you do okay yeah yeah
yeah that's good that's good hey you
good to get basket I said no oh I guess
it must have gotten Ross in the email
yeah you know about that
that old kind of hacking thing really
screwed us over I mean the movie got
pulled that's not my phone I'm not the
one who talked him and pull your film
from theater because of some
five-foot-two dictator across the globe
listen Kim we're all just people you
have a voice I have a voice and I use my
voice to make up the facets that create
the human condition so I can tell movies
you've got a really good job making
people think you're smart for some
reason but they really make no sense I
know right every time you pontificate I
just want to take a nap and smoke some
weed temptation of christ he trashed
American soldiers all the time yeah
avatar just some big anti-american
screed painted naked blue you know
you're supposed to be brave
Frank a guy getting the Lord you know I
guess I haven't gone gay enough for an
award yet yeah it's true no he's pretty
gay in his off time I never want your
movie to get bad I'm a big fan says
what's that moving you pray where you
are you make the jokes why smoking all
the weed oh yeah man not about narrows
it down knew all
James you should probably go back to
spider-man cuz I must set someone of
your movie they pretty much crap yeah
you know he's got a point there he's
right
I've written 18 novels yeah but you also
made fry boys so listen I want to help
you guys out I'm gonna make a few phone
calls okay and I'm only gonna give you
some advice okay yeah yeah you ready for
it
yes okay read my ribs grow some balls
okay thatís all your problem Hollywood
but I gotta get going hey Seth you you
haven't have big plans for today yeah I
don't know maybe go home and uh smoke
some more weed oh man you are on a roll
I really hope you get your old Hollywood
star fame said you deserve it
yeah you deserve it you know who Jesus
was never married Muhammad seemingly
favorite wife was a shoe who according
to was around 6:00 though to be fair he
only consummated when she was nine